benvenuti e bentornati solita stress
oggi il nuovo video 24 ore oggi
passeremo 24 ore in terrazzo nel nostro
terrazzo
poi tutto vuoto chi se li dice berlino
li berlino che devo dire stai all'ombra
lo scorso video 24 ore in giardino o
nella tenda vi è piaciuto tantissimo e
ha superato i 30 mila mi piace quindi
come promesso ecco un altro video 24 ore
anche questo video supera il 30 mila mi
piace faremo un altro video 24 ore
quindi lasciate un bel mi piace vi
prendete i pop corn e buona visione
ok ora di pranzo finalmente vediamo cosa
ha preparato vitale per pranzo la mole
scatolini avvento quindi sono fatte ok
quello contorni e dessert e pane spero
che non è
non li ho già in agguato pronto
abbiamo una specie di frittatina con i
fiori di zucca i capperi e le zucchine
queste l'ha fatta la mamma di vitale che
bravissimo territorio indirizzata olive
buon appetito
lo mangiamo assieme per noi il super
divertente fare questi video perché ci
sembra di passare una giornata intera
assieme a volte lo può cantare come il
terrazzo l'altra volta era nel giardino
con la tenda anche se stanotte
probabilmente metteremo la tenda anche
qui in giardino
anche qui in terrazzo gerardo difficile
vedere le stelle l'altra volta non ci
siamo riusciti perché era nuvoloso ma
oggi stanotte non dovrebbe essere quindi
speriamo di riuscire a vedere bene
assieme
c'è una giornata fantastica si fa
caldissimo ok passiamo ora al secondo di
lucca domani a noi che si è che brava
ragazzi incredibile rimasto tutto
intatto sbattuto per terra
allora abbiamo il pane fragole e
zucchine
un pezzo di partito sempre mangiare con
un cane se avete un cane software cosa
sto parlando che ti fissa
se ti guarderà sperando che gli dai un
pezzetto di qualcosa qui si reca sempre
al boca un pronto per mangiare qualcosa
che ride io adoro le fragole bruttissime
che buone
berlino non ti piacciono le fragole e
inutile che ci guardi così ciao ragazzi
vi ricordate che nell'altro video 24 ore
di tale mi ha fatto uno scherzo e mi
sono anche spaventato tantissimo io ho
preparato vari scherzetti da fargli eco
chic così mi posso vendicare una di
questi scherzetti e questo ho preso due
pistole d'acqua e sto aspettando che lui
si addormenti perché ora è appunto in
terrazzo sulla sdraio sta aspettando che
si addormenti e poi andrò parlo della di
vedere la sua reazione così impara a
farvi quegli scherzi ragazzo ha avuto
un'altra idea ho trovato qua nel freezer
del ghiaccio prima di spruzzarlo con la
pistola mi metterò del ghiaccio addosso
che si si sfoga interven corre di più
[Musica]
marmo
stai di nando
[Musica]
[Risate]
non ti avvicinare
altrimenti subirai mila persone aspetti
che è finita l'acqua
devo correre ai ripari bene i ragazzi in
missione compiuta il primo scherzo è
riuscito ma non è l'unico scherzo di
oggi perché mi farò un altro scherzetto
ora vitale scappava e conca stato troppo
divertente o riso talmente oggi che mi
farà tappa fans non vede l'ora di
rivedere questa sera 500 volte lui era
scappato quindi ora il terrazzo è tutto
per me chi la fa l'aspetti e ora
mettiamo la tenda per stanotte 32
è gigante non ci sta dobbiamo metterlo
al contrario ciao ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla cena infatti come potete vedere è
buio siamo entrati nella tenda perché
c'è un po di vento stanotte purtroppo
infatti un pò inquietante perché la
tenda si muove da sola deve speriamo ci
sarà qualche incontro strano berlino
come sempre vuole rubarci il cibo come e
non solo marlin o poi vediamo se
riusciamo a vedere le stelle assieme
cosa abbiamo per cenare abbiamo un
merlino che perché allora abbiamo in
asse con la salsa piccante quali nel in
umile calcò perché con lui vitale ha
preparato il burrito dissi un po cosa
sei dentro questa burrito allora c'è il
riso o poi gironi fagioli fagioli al
sugo con lotta peroncino
poi c'è la cipolletta il prezzemolo
anche se non ci andrebbe apprezziamo in
realtà mi sa che è così c'è altro
le salse difficilissimo match 3 con un
cane di tutto bene mordiamo guardiamo
subito borella dell'adige parlerà dentro
il letto pochissimo non scorderete cosa
c'è dentro ma del buonissimo montebuono
avete mai mangiato cibo messicano dico
che giammai
buonissima la tazzina messicana noi
siamo ok
ogni tanto si sente qualche rumore
strano ho mai fatto venire curiosità
adesso manca vorrei si lascia un attimo
da parte la dwars il riso è super crei
moto con i fagioli pomodori buoni di mou
non potete vedere la faccia di berlino
ma è molto arrabbiato perché vuole che
gli diamo un pezzo di burrito militare
per non sbagliare visto di farne i buoni
ha fatto però perché sommini burrito
guarda non è che sono da sempre la
solita sinda
l'uomo lui punto subito il burrito va
bene ti do un pezzettino di buono è per
fortuna abbiamo un berlino che fa la
guardia perché un po inquietante quali
non berlino guardia fa la guardia nel
senso che guarda voi con noi mancava da
guardie solo il cibo che uguale a te
comunque c'è una cosa strana qua in
questa casa praticamente ogni notte
sempre ogni notte
sentiamo un grido che è tipo un grido
che sembra un gatto non e pensavamo
fosse un gatto però si sente amplificato
con una voce potentissima e quindi non
abbiamo capito esattamente che cos'è ma
pensiamo che sia un uccello perché fa
davvero così se ti fosse spaventare
quello non era proprio il verso di un
gatto
speriamo di sentirlo in casa notte così
anche voi magari se siete esperti potesi
dirci che animale merlino cambiato
l'alto per vedere mamma mia sto ladro
del burrito eccolo qua siamo già al
secondo burrito che buono l'italia
secondo che non s'è fatto il secondo
bowling con l'uccello 9 dovuto si avesse
titolo forse non si sentiva perché stavo
parlando
dov'è il dessert oggi non ho fatto due
serre nonno in realtà non mangiamo
tantissimi dolci anche se evita le
mangerebbe dolci tutto il giorno della
motiva sera così come dolce mangiamo la
frutta
fruttato ma no merlino mettevano
commenti se anche i vostri cani erutta
aiuto o due prodotto e non posso francia
comunque a parte gli scherzi è sempre
così quando mangio perché io mangio più
lentamente di loro ovviamente che sono
due cavi la capitale un cane e quindi
loro mi fissano sperano che gli dia un
pezzettino del mio cibo che ragazzi ora
che vitale ronzano ne approfitto è
andato forse di là i piatti approfitto
per spiegarvi velocemente il piano
praticamente ho preso un lenzuolo bianco
lungo e far finta di essere un fantasma
spero spero che vitali si spaventi
tantissimo e non so bene magari lo
chiudono dentro la tenda così capisce
che c'è qualcosa che non va
comunque spero che creda che sia un
povero fantasma così si spaventerà un
sacco lasciate un bel mi piace soldi che
possono altri scherzi a vitale io mi
diverto tantissimo ora sta tornando
io ora vado poi non mi vedrete mi
vedrete solo nella prospettiva di vita
ciao come qua vista sia da sultanato un
attimino
lo ha detto che doveva fare qualcosa non
ho capito bene cosa e io sono qui come
arrivi netto che si sta accomodando il
lino così quasi ci mettiamo a guardare
le stelle che ne pensate
perdiamo un po
alla fine il cielo purtroppo è per
nuvoloso e non si vede praticamente un
bel niente bene e tutti e due siamo io e
marley netto erli netto vieni a guardare
le stelle competere in cile
si no ieri un peccato purtroppo più che
neanche questa volta sono vedere le
stelle perché è super nuvoloso
mannaggia e c'è pure tanto vento ieri
c'e nessuno che era
cosa aiuta dove posso aiutarla aiutare
marino aiutami è una cosa bianca che si
può perché e io do santo marino quando
prima neve di aiuto nel rigo ha fatto un
arrivo
passiamo ora vino attacca in questo
fantasma desire non sia molto bravo
qualcosa intanto si è lasciato prendere
da merlino questo contesto si chiama beh
diciamo che non sei pronto nissimo farmi
gli scherzi e perché no paura all'inizio
ma poi dopo un cattivo di ritmo
marino deve sempre proteggerci sì io
volevo fargli uno scherzo spaventosa
come hai fatto tu con me di berlino è
troppo protettivo e la nostra guardia
del corpo e quindi pensavo davvero che
vitale fosse in pericolo e lo ha subito
protetto smascherato riunita una sorta
di scooby doo riesce smascherare tutti
mostri comunque ora vediamo se riusciamo
a vedere le stelle speriamo
vediamole lo scivoloso e vediamo vediamo
anche se riusciamo a sentire
quel verso strano guardate quante per le
stelle
non so se riuscite a vederle bene dal
video ma ci sono tantissime stelle
bellissime bisognerebbe sempre trovare
il tempo di portarli di puntare il naso
sul cielo e ora con queste stelle
magiche esprimete un desiderio e ora li
lasciano qua 4 casellina si può cercare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella dopo le ferie e buona visione
e stato bellissimo passare 24
[Musica]